wer weiß schon freuen
jeder tag ist
er weiß schon heute wo wir morgen sind
wieder alles neu begeht
wir kochen heute vegan und der matthias
zeigt nur heute was denn hier aus dem
kühlschrank alles raus muss wenn man
wirklich wigan leben
matthias ist nicht alles aus den küchen
käse drin fresh milchbauer josef reckels
also vegan heißt das du auf alle
tierischen produkte verzichtet und das
bedeutet nicht nur dass du keine toten
tiere ist sondern dass du jedes produkt
nicht konsumiert was irgendwie mal von
einem tier kam das klingt am anfang nach
ziemlich viel zeit aber es bleibt
wahnsinnig wenn er überlegt der manche
tiere er die streichung bringen sie zum
tierarzt und sorgen uns viel darum dass
es ihm gut geht und bei anderen tieren
die verstecken wir im dunkeln und
schlachten siegen und essen sie hat was
hast du denn jetzt da heute vor gehörte
eigentlich es ist so soja eiweiß das ist
trocken hält sich ewig ja und ist halt
einfach die antwort auf jeden
fleischskandal weil da ist nicht
irgendwie an die bürgerinnen also
schmeckt ein bisschen nach oben
an sich ich bin es nicht war raich hat
die erfahrung gemacht dass es relativ
billig ist denkst du dass dir was viel
geht dir was ab ja manchmal und zwar ein
ganz spezifisch sache käse käse schmeckt
ob besonders
wir machen eine sahnesoße team als eine
käse sahne so ist wo kein käse drin ist
die aber nach käse schmecken das ist
auch so tief locken
nicht so toll aber wenn sich das auflöst
dann bindet es erst zweite schmeckt eben
wie ein käse sowie ein bisschen brühe
ist man auf dann nehmen wir so eine soja
sahne und jetzt tun wir eben diese hefe
glockenrein fertig hettich minuten 59
das habe ich hier das war's dann oder ja
ich finde das wetter perfekt aus okay
ich hab hunger auf geht's so bin ich
gespannt
ist gut sehr gut sogar danke matthias
heute ich hab sehr viel dazugelernt viel
zum nachdenken
bis zum nächsten mal der scc sofa